who are these figures here who's Trotsky
who's Lenin who's Stalin what are some
interesting aspects of all of this what
a sort of just to linger on it the
personalities the ideas that were
important well Trotsky came late to
bolshevism he was really the brains in
many ways of the October Revolution he
was an amazing strategist he never
forgot that he was amazing strategist
had a very high opinion of himself and
by the way the October Revolution 1917
that's a key moment
um
of course the the Russian Revolution
lasted a long time but this was a key
moment of uh what a phase shift towards
success
of the Bolsheviks well that was the
moment that was like all right we are
the government now and now we have to
make it's a you know like Thomas
Jefferson said I think it was Thomas
Jefferson or no it's Ben Franklin uh a
republic if you can keep it it's like
all right we've made our own kind of
government if we can keep it because
that was the big question you got an
international blockade you had the white
armies the tsars forces who want to
restore zaraism or at least the the
parliament from uh right before Landon
took over so this was a big kind of no
one's was you know in some ways it was
like the 2016 election it's like all
right we vote in Trump what's this going
to look like like no one no one had any
idea of what a trump presidency was
going to look like all we knew was this
guy's on Twitter running his mouth he's
insulting people and he's had all these
views somewhere over here some over
there and the funny thing is the
Russians hacked both elections
see that's true it was Putin in the
gremlin so Trotsky was you know Lenin's
right-hand man
um and he was you know enormous and to
this day a he remains this kind of
figure who is
supposedly a less authoritarian
anti-stalinist version of Communism that
people can endorse and Stalin of course
was Lenin's successor at first there was
a triumvirate running Russia as Lenin
was recuperating from Strokes then very
quickly not very quickly but gradually
and then suddenly Stalin became an
absolute dictator and he had a series of
uh of purges and so and so forth which
solidified his control over the country
and of course for Stalin Trotsky later
but throughout as you write seemed to
almost take on a supernatural character
wherein everything that went wrong in
the USSR was due not just to his views
but to his direct orders from abroad and
uh of course George Orwell brilliantly
and probably my favorite book of his
which is animal farm and also in 1984.
portrayed Trotsky as a a snowball and
Animal Farm and Emmanuel Goldstein in uh
1984 is this embodiment of this evil
that will always have to be fighting
then you need that in order to hold
on to power you always have to have that
enemy right so that I mean that's
something I talk about uh in in the
white pill as well when things start
going wrong they always have to have
scapegoats right and there's this
Russian egg dot you know what the
Russians like to do is you can't say
things out loud but if you make jokes
you can say unspeakable truths and
there's this one anecdote where there's
a Russian leader and things are going
bad and he looks in his drawer and there
were two letters from his predecessor
and he opens the first letter in a panic
and the letter says you know for advice
and the letter says blame everything on
me so he goes out there and he's like oh
my predecessor sucked he was terrible
blah blah it's his fault and everyone's
like okay and then there's a Calamity
again and he's like a crap so it goes
back at his desk and he reads the second
one and it says sit down and write two
letters so when things start going wrong
as they constantly did throughout the
history of the Soviet Union uh or any
you know totalitarian authoritarian
country it's someone has to be the blame
since we know that our idea theology is
true and scientifically true if it's not
working in reality given the Perfection
of the ideology someone must be
intentionally undermining it and causing
the disconnect between thought and
reality and in the Soviet Union there
were there was a cool locks at one point
then it was the Wreckers uh the doctors
it was just different the cap there was
always someone and Trotsky uh was called
a fascist and was accused of plotting
with Hitler and all this other stuff